huit mois d'emprisonnement avec sursis
et 25000 euros damende ont été
prononcées contre serge morvan l'ancien
préfet des yvelines comparaissait ce
matin devant l'ag du tribunal de
versailles dans le cadre d'une audience
de comparution avec reconnaissance
préalable de culpabilité
il ya des faits qui ont été commis dans
une perspective qui était un souci de
discrétion que tout le monde a compris
les sommes ont été remboursées
immédiatement voilà il et les faits sont
retenus avec une ampleur un peu excessif
par le parquet mais c'est le principe de
la crpc
ils sont reconnus tonte à petit je crois
qu'il faut passer à autre chose
pour rappel les faits reprochés
remontent à plusieurs années lorsqu'il
était encore en fonction de 2015 à 2018
l'ancien préfet a produit des faux bond
de mariage fabriquer une fausse
nomination à l'elysée et infos
spermogramme il a aussi détourné des
fonds publics à des fins personnelles
on parle quand même de 1200 euros de
décence sur trois ans est de 2500 euros
de de télépéage sur trois ans et dix
mille euros de dépenses sur trois ans
ses dépenses et à tester non contesté
ces dépenses étaient compensées par le
préfet morvan qui effectué sur ses
deniers personnels des dépenses à
caractère professionnel des agissements
qui lui permettait d'entretenir dans le
secret une relation avec sa maîtresse
c'est grâce à elle que l' affaire a été
révélée
elle a porté plainte en 2018 pour
violences et abus de l'état frauduleux
deux faiblesses et en 2019 les faits ont
été requalifiés dans les termes retenus
aujourd'hui pour la victime cette
audience est une façon de tourner
définitivement la page
son statut de victime ait été reconnu
encore une fois comme je le disais ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas une évidence dans
une procédure de cette nature-là dirigée
contre une personne de cette importance
que la procédure aille à son terme je
pense que l a eu un vrai chemin de
bataille et elle est contente que ça
soit terminé
l'ancien préfet a accepté la peine il
dispose tout de même de 10 jours pour
faire appel